hey guys Pete here back with another
dark video today this will be a
breakdown on the family trees and
character connections and Netflix's dark
and the story where everything is
connected things can get a little bit
complicated and this video will sort out
everything we've seen so far for you we
learned a lot about who is related to
who in season 2 so this does contain
spoilers if you aren't caught up through
that and with that out of the way let's
break this down one of my favorite
things in season 2 of dark is Adams wall
of photos that we get a look at in the
1921 timeline season one gave us the
string wall that presumably older
Claudia put together in the future after
the apocalypse it was in the bunker but
Adam won upped her with his fantastic
display while there are still mysteries
that remain in the family trees we can
reasonably explain how the four families
in the 2019 photos are related and
connected they are all central to the
story and are displayed at the center of
Adam's wall I think the Nielsen's are
the best place to start so we can go
from there the Nielsen family in 2019 is
older I can Katarina they were high
school sweethearts that got married they
end up having three children Magnus is
their oldest Marta is the middle child
and Michael is the youngest in November
of 2019 at age 11 Mikkel time travels
through the caves getting stuck in 1986
in that same month
Ulrich travels through the caves looking
for him but he ends up getting stuck in
1953 Michael is eventually adopted by
his nurse Ines con wolde he grows to
adulthood and becomes Michael Conlon we
know Ulrich's parents taranta and Jana
as they are still both alive in 2019 we
get the idea that they never got over
the disappearance of Ulrich's brother
Mads Nielsen who went missing in 1986
mad dies after being kidnapped
no one Helga were behind this they were
using him to test the time travel chair
that is in the bunker they send him to
2019 through it but he dies in the
process because the chair isn't fully
operational yet Agnes Nielsen is
Toronto's mother which makes her
Ulrich's grandmother she came to windin
in 1953 with a young taranta in tow and
moved
in with the tea demands Agnes is
mysterious and there's a lot of
questions that follow her around all so
young taranta told young Claudia that he
was in a home before they came to windin
so it's not a hundred percent confirmed
that Agnes is his biological mother we
also don't know for sure who her husband
was and thus where she picked up the
Nielson name she does mention that she
was married to a pastor who was not a
good person but that only leads the
speculation of who that might be
we do know that Agnes grew up in the
care of Erna
in London in the 1921 timeline it's not
clear if Erna is the biological mother
of both her and her brother Noah though
we do know that she takes people in so
that could be a reference to taking Noah
and Agnes in' in the first place in 1953
Agnes has an affair with Doris Tiedemann
and then later their children claudia
Tiedemann and taranta Nielsen have an
affair in the 1980s as mention Mikkel
Nielsen travels back in time from 2019
to 1986 and he gets himself stuck there
he ends up being adopted by inez Khan
Wald so he is a Neilsen by blood but a
con wolde by name this also means that
Ulrich is Jonas's grandfather the 2019
Khan one family is Michael who used to
be Mikkel Hannah Jonas and Michael's
adopted mother anise anise his father
was Daniel con wolde he was the chief of
police in 1953 we see that he works with
Egon Tiedemann and this his mother is
unknown we hear of her but we never see
her Hannah who married Michael
unknowingly ends up sleeping with his
father when she starts to have an affair
with Ulrich Jonas con wolde falls in
love with Marta Nielsen which of course
turns out to be his aunt Jonas is the
central character in dark we see him at
three different ages in the story he
starts out in 2019 as a teenager his
older self who we referred to as the
stranger shows up in windin in the
beginning of season one and then we
learned that there's another older Jonas
who his younger self meets in the 1921
timeline this version goes by the name
of
and at the end of season two we aren't
exactly sure how he progresses from
being the character who was the stranger
into his add himself but we do know that
Adam has created a group called SiC
mundus older Magnus is a member of that
for sure
older Franziska is almost certainly a
member and this other member here could
definitely be an older bartosh that is
the theory that some people think they
look a lot alike this character has been
cold Magnus he's been referred to by his
name so we know that he's an older
version of Magnus Nielsen but the other
two are only speculation because those
characters look like they could be them
and we know that they traveled with the
middle Jonas he saved them by taking
them through time right before the
apocalypse happen Hannah
ends up time-traveling to 1954 to go
look for Ulrich she tells the police
that she thought he might be her husband
but after talking to him she realizes
that he favors Katarina and his family
over her and decides to leave him in the
facility but she decides that she's
gonna start a new life in the 1950s as
far as we can tell there's also a hint
here that she may have taken interest in
Egon Tiedemann because he's basically
Ulrich's nemesis throughout the years
that we see these two characters
interact and we saw Egon discussing the
possibility of having an affair with
Ennis's father Daniel con wall speaking
of the t demons the 2019 Tiedemann
family consists of Regina Alexander and
Bartok's
of course Regina's mother is Claudia who
is a very important character she was
the head of the power plant but went
missing in 1987 she ages up to become
the oldest version of her that we see
running around doing all sorts of
important things but as far as we can
tell that she had never contacted Regina
after leaving in 1987 so nobody knows
where she's at the identity of Regina's
father is unknown
Claudia never had a husband that we've
seen but she does have an affair with
Toronto which we see in season one this
has led to the theory that he's Regina's
father but it's not confirmed in any way
Claudia's parents are Egon and Doris who
both are seemingly unhappy in their
mayor
Alexander T demons real name is Boris
nee wolde but he took the identity of
someone named Alexander Koehler when he
first moved to wind and and then took on
Regina's last name when they married
Claussen is the brother of the real
Alexander caller which was the original
reason he came to windin to lead the
task force into the six missing persons
cases we don't know who Boris slash
Alexander's family is why he showed up
in the woods in windin in 1986 but it's
likely that it will be important since
everything is so connected in windin the
2019 Doppler family is Peter Charlotte
Franziska and Elizabeth Peters father is
Helga we don't know who his mother is
and his entire backstory is confusing
because he mentions arriving in windin
in 1987 either way he refers to Helga's
his father and I imagine we're gonna
learn more about his backstory in season
3 Helga's parents are burnt and Greta
burns started the nuclear plant in
windin we see him later pass it on to
Claudia to take over when he retires
Greta does make a statement that
indicates that burnt might not be
Helga's biological father but he seems
to care for the boy as his own so there
might be some mystery there but Bern
doesn't seem to be affected by it
Charlotte's father is Noah and this
basically means that her family is
related to everyone through taranta who
would be Charlotte's cousin the big
Doppler family reveal in season two of
dark was that Charlotte and Elizabeth
are each other's mothers this had a lot
of people confused at the end of season
two but we have to remember that while
there is a linear timeline that we can
follow when you introduce time travel
you're introducing all these different
loops that don't adhere to that linear
time line so what happened is basically
this young Elizabeth and young Noah
survived the apocalypse and the bunker
together we assume that later they must
have started a relationship and
Elizabeth gave birth to a baby Charlotte
later Charlotte was raised by a CG ten
house the clockmaker he became her
adoptive grandfather considering he's
responsible for creating the time
machine and was visited by claudia and
older Jonas throughout the story we
assume some
brought him Charlotte to take care of
her we don't know why but it turns out
that Charlotte then grows up among older
ekaterina and Hanna's generation in the
80s and goes on to marry Peter Doppler
they later have two children Francisca
and Elizabeth because Noah is
Charlotte's father and Elizabeth is
Charlotte's daughter that makes Noah
Elizabeth's grandfather as well as
Francisco's it also makes Elizabeth her
own grandmother as well as her sister
Francisco's grandmother that would also
mean that Peter is her grandfather well
it can be confusing it certainly does
make sense inside of the time travel
narrative that we were given so there
could be more reveals like this to come
in season three we also have other
characters that don't immediately fit
into the family trees of the four major
families we have two known Wohlers on
the show benny the sex worker and torben
who works with the police
peter doppler had an affair with Benny
and Torben works with Charlotte
otherwise we don't know where these two
connect to the big families in windin
but considering how much screen time
they've received it seems like that
there will be more to learn about their
story in the future it appears that
their mother probably worked with him as
at the hospital but it's not confirmed
also fans really want to know about how
Torben zai was injured and they kind of
teased that in season two but didn't pay
it off the girl in the future Celia is
completely mysterious at this point Adam
has her photo displayed below the main
families on his board
she works alongside older Elizabeth as
her translator but we have no idea who
her family is or when she came from
Claussen played a big role in starting
the apocalypse we learned that Claussen
is actually his wife's name and we know
that his brother was Alexander Kohler
because Boris niwa took over that
identity after he arrived in windin
Claussen took over the missing persons
case because he got a letter from an
unknown source telling him that he could
find answers about his brother in windin
all this makes you wonder who the
koehlers are and how boris knee Wald's
arrival fits into the bigger picture
there are a lot of great visual family
trees out there that he'll
when you can't remember all the
characters names they have the photos
next to the names they show them at
different ages and things like that this
text based one on the dark wiki that was
put together by the user afflicted
horror is one of my favorites though I
like how without the distractions the
holes in what we know stand out really
well especially in relation to know and
Agnes's parents of course Erna could be
their mother but either way we can see
how whoever they are would be connected
to everyone in these four families it
also shines a light on how we have a few
characters here that are pretty major
players who have children but we've
never actually met their partner or have
a good idea of where that child came
from like Helga and Claudia and of
course Agnes
that's pretty much all we know for sure
at the end of dark season 2 there are a
lot of mysteries and a lot of theories
have been popping up that are pretty
interesting I'm not gonna go into those
in this video though bartosh Magnus and
Francisca all traveled with stranger
aids Jonas and we've already seen that
Elizabeth had a child post apocalypse
and we understand that the looping
nature means that obviously these people
can go back in time and father or mother
someone who already exists in the later
timelines seeing that they're all
teenagers when they go makes it pretty
likely that they're going to have some
children or do something that's going to
add to this family tree later on down
the road let me know in the comments
what questions you want to see answered
about the dark family trees in season 3
what reveals are you hoping for and tell
me about the crazy theories that you're
following personally I'm most interested
in knowing and Agnes's parents and who
so Leah will turn out to be my next
video will be all about the questions I
have going into the next season please
like this video if you enjoyed it and
subscribe to my channel if you like dark
and other TV shows like it thanks for
watching I will talk to you soon